oh no no no no no no no no how's it
going Reza display is about to crash
well a better Christ drunk Oh
martini how long let's let that [ __ ] on
fire
best martini ever alright guys I see you
on the other side head back to your seat
it's gonna be a long flight
I have a feeling it's not gonna be that
long all right well [ __ ] it
Yello I'm not sure but I don't think
they're supposed to be a whole there
guys over on the water I better save the
captain
if only this trade table wasn't in the
all right yet to direct this is exactly
like by your shot are we gonna get
something today
[ __ ] oh oh alright well that's
convenient what a great service I mean
ah Sh I check believe I survived
I better paddle I'll call I can paddle
inside the boat I gotta say it's very
pretty
I like the colors alright cool why
paddle in the ocean when you can paddle
anyway cool this reminds me of forest a
lot but I think it has more substance I
mean look we have a sick look at that
hey pets 6 don't talk mr. Crabbe that's
dr. Crabbe excuse me very much hi talks
oh look there's so many of them you're
so kawaii
I have a doctorate I don't deserve this
oh my god so many that's so cute hey
what are you doing every crab I can stab
them look at that dr. crab I just
murdered your entire family how does
that make you feel
who's the doctor now why don't you save
them if you're such a good doctor and
why is your family dead alright that was
pretty dark and horrible let's try and
make a campfire I got on dos três Loompa
da dee da da de Merida I'm a pretty good
climber I gotta hand it to myself haha
Oh coconuts me I am alright ah ah I
think my arm is broke we need to make
some some crafting tools I looked up
online how you make them oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] oh my god oh [ __ ] we're gonna
we're gonna come oh my god we're gonna
make a hammer it's kind of fun I you
just [ __ ] throw this [ __ ] there and
be like there it's a habit can't you see
it nailed it dr. crab crab calling dr.
crab happy I
i feeI yeah FBI you singing cram right
vio let me I shut up let's chop down
this palm tree it looks like it's good
in erecting are you into this you like
in a dance there we go
hey we built a raft I'm probably gonna
regret this but we need to go to another
Island I'm sailing away please no sharks
I'm allergic
please no sharks please no sharks please
no sharks oh there's something here oh
my god oh I have to explore this but
there could be sharks Oh new world I
need to stop singing seriously oh [ __ ] a
[ __ ] fish scare the [ __ ] out of me
what's that oh no no no no no mom mom
mom going going oh you've done it now
you [ __ ] [ __ ] I have a gun I have a
[ __ ] gun I'm gonna go and I'm gonna
gonna gonna gonna go and go and go go go
go get up get up on the raft you idiot
ah you piece of [ __ ] raft all right
we'll only got a [ __ ] gun [ __ ] yes
[ __ ] saved where are we going anyway
a whole new world am I getting tanned
ah nice nice and crispy lemon and then
man if this is real life I'd be fine
this is easy
what rafty crafty rusty what the where
you go well who needs a raft to paddle I
sure as hell don't
oh no no no no no no no no no no no oh
[ __ ]
don't make me [ __ ] you
I can't even [ __ ] it I can't even
[ __ ] shoot it the swimsuit zip sensor
that's the morning I'm not gonna do it
again please please baby hello baby out
baby [ __ ] it out
[ __ ] it off it out oh my god oh my god
[ __ ] ah yeah that's right I have a
[ __ ] [ __ ] look come here
[ __ ] [ __ ] you oh you [ __ ] ass [ __ ]
[ __ ] oh oh oh I'm riding a pool I'm
riding a shark faster faster
I'm gonna kick on this date that's
[ __ ] right I'm gonna finish his swim
the man I'm gonna work at might add a
little bit more think we handle ed
pretty well oh no no no no no no no he
brought his fans he brought his friends
he brought her Harkins ha ha ha Oh
potato say something stupid but take oh
you're a coconut that's why god dammit
that was [ __ ] horrible I can't even
tell it for a new island oh no [ __ ]
way we swam in [ __ ] circles
video game finally we made it to a new
island
hey potatoes I don't know you can find
these on an island let's see if we can
eat the potato in the hole
dammit dammit oh ah potato tower ah [ __ ]
you'll never be a potato tower throw it
shut up [ __ ] this is how you build
build real proper beds from Ikea I'm
Swedish so I know this Wow you can only
sleep at night I've done something in my
life it's something dr. crab I made you
a little bit there you go well [ __ ] you
too then dr. kramm ha oh damn dr. crab
I'm so sorry it's just wearing a hat
it's just a hat
you look great dr. crab Oh Sharky shoo
you [ __ ]
why don't you bleed what is this fight
me in real life mate
think I'm scared of you you piece a [ __ ]
that bucket
it's not worth it it's not worth it
alright what the [ __ ] is wrong with ya
[ __ ] we're not through we're not
through
okay so we first build a base dit dit
dit dit dit dit dit dit dit drop the
base dad we're not just put it there
then we need to build a sport boom boom
alright it's been a long day me and crab
I gonna go to sleep
Aloha huh do you like our new house dr.
crab sorry dr. crab was it Oh dr. crab
you don't have to sleep with me
all right now I'm dead it there but I
hope you enjoyed this video if you want
more please hit that like button and I
will be sure to do whatever you want to
have [ __ ] out
thank your watching and as always stay
on bro